we invented seed to sale tracking we
currently serve businesses and
governments worldwide we operate and
offer technology services across the
entire supply chain so cultivation
manufacturing distribution and retail
over ten billion dollars of sales
transactions to date through our
technology systems and we have three
core values that we live by they are do
the right thing be part of the solution
and show people you care what's up
everyone welcome to simulation we are
still at new West Summit in partnership
with them the world's leading cannabis
tech conference we are now sitting down
with Jessica Billingsley the CEO of MJ
freeway thank you for coming on the show
and the moment that I came in through
the door I saw you know MJ freeway and
then we started talking about you and I
then it was like acquisition time and
publicly traded time and I was like whoa
okay cool let's like let's unpack more
let's understand more what do you do
wise how are you already at this stage
there's so many early-stage cannabis
tech companies and then you're like
we've been around eight and a half years
so that's a pretty I guess a long time
for cannabis company to have to be
around go ahead and yet teach us about
what your what your what you've built
and you know how it all got started and
we'd love to learn
sure well thank you so MJ freeway we
invented seed to sale tracking as you as
you mentioned a little over eight and a
half years ago and we currently serve
businesses and governments worldwide
we're the only cannabis technology
company that is operating truly globally
and we operate and offer technology
services across the entire supply chain
so cultivation manufacturing
distribution and retail and we have
processed as you mentioned earlier over
ten billion dollars of sales
transactions to date through our
technology systems how does one know how
to put a unique idea
a fire to a seed and then see it trick
go all the way to sell without telling
us about your secret sauces but how do
you do that well I think I'm not sure if
I'll be able to answer that without
getting very very technically geeky so
maybe I'll answer ok ok so at the end of
the day it's the it's a parent-child
association in the software program and
many many of those so as you you attach
a unique identifier to the seed to the
tissue culture or the clone throughout
propagation and any additives anything
that happens throughout the lifecycle of
growing all of those are included and
get attached to the history and
ingredients that are used in the growth
of the product can actually move forward
as ingredients in the final product
so that unique identifier then becomes a
parent identifier if you will or or a
child and multiple plants might be
combined into one batch which then
becomes the parent with all the child
batches and then even that batch might
be it might go through an extraction or
an infusion process but we attach and
track it throughout the entire process
and all of those ingredients that could
have happened since inception still
follow through to the sale of the final
product which also assists in recalls as
well ok so all the way from the parent
so you're really looking you you started
eight years ago with labeling the unique
identifier on two different strains and
different plant and and then then it was
their seeds and then you would label
their seeds and then this has now been a
continuous process of just labeling
their seeds from the so you kind of have
a ancestry well we certainly have a
large set of data around genetics if you
will but we don't necessarily label
seeds from all the parents that have
ever existed so in our system though
there might be a mother or a grandma
their plant and then there might be
clones or tissue culture or seeds that
come from those plants that live on in
the system at a particular clients
facility and we do have all of that set
of data of genetics that that can be
tracked through the system to each other
is that maybe we stay there for a little
bit if that's an interesting aspect to
what MJ freeway is doing it is genetic
plant genetics data cannabis genetics is
that an interesting field for you guys
to work with other scientists and what
are you discovering there is that an
interesting part of it is I think that
one of the interesting things with plant
genetics now is that you can take the
same clone or the same tissue culture of
the same strain even from the same
mother or grandmother plant and you can
actually end up with a different
phenome at the end when it gets sent to
the laboratory for testing so there's
just a lot more data and science work to
be done in that area and and we are
partnering with other folks to work on
some of those issues and interesting
challenges and opportunities and then
now let's maybe talk about the rest of
the process so now how do you track the
unique identifiers all the way to sale
sure so it lives and it all it gets
associated throughout the entire process
whether it gets in Phoenix tracted into
an axe extract whether that extract then
gets infused into another product all of
the information from the original
material stays attached to it throughout
the system and then that moves through
and the sale can be tracked to sale to a
final patient or consumer as well so
then you're relying on all of the
components that are if they are added
along the way to be logged well yes
although there is a lot that is set up
to be really smart really intuitive
where you can you can have perform an
action that happens to an entire room
for instance and and one additive gets
out it's everything that's located in
that room so
there's a lot that we do to cut down on
the manual data entry from a technology
user user interface usability point of
view okay and then this is really
important because then we are your your
your in your in essence you are a
immutable ledger of the data that is so
you are kind of a blockchain but you're
all you you're a mute your mutable data
on the product a ledger of the product
you don't actually have a annum you this
is this a blockchain so not technically
and I'll explain why so there are two
things that make blockchain watching one
is this idea of an immutable system of
record which we absolutely are but
interestingly and and actually wrote a
blog about this what makes blockchain
blockchain is that it is also
peer-reviewed and unless you were
centralized well we have a set of
technology solutions we actually are a
cloud hosted solution for what we
provide however we're we are one entity
and we provide these solutions to our to
our clients and in order to actually be
black chain you have you would have to
have a appear entity actually review
every transaction before it becomes a
transaction and and then it actually
makes it so it's not ever or at least
not in today's technology in terms of
what's possible it's not a replacement
won't be a replacement for traditional
databases or database systems for
business management transaction systems
which are you know what we offer so if
somebody is needing to make a sale they
can't wait on somebody else some other
peer review that sale before they make
the sale which is what makes blockchain
blockchain for now which is exciting too
because then then everything can be
completely decentralized at the same
time that it is immutable ok cool that
was that was that's good that we got
that we learned about that so now how
does one scale from 210 billion in sales
over
for eight years how does one do that
well I think there are a couple pieces
but number one you have to provide the
most value to your clients and we think
about that all the time how do we solve
their problems better than anyone else
so we actually have a very defined
culture in MJ freeway and we have three
core values that we live by they are do
the right thing be part of the solution
and show people you care and if you're
doing all of those things really really
well by definition any great technology
provides far more value to either the
top line or the bottom line then it
costs it provides more value to our
clients and and that's how we've been
able to lead through the years
Wow those are cool one more time please
do the right thing be part of the
solution and show people you care do the
right thing be part of the solution and
show people you care those are really
good and that's how you can really build
a really strong team so how many people
are with you now we're about 80 people
and is that a lot of Engineers the
computer scientists or were you at with
the array of people sure well we
certainly have a very strong and deep
and experienced team of engineers but we
also have throughout our company that
continued to hire from within the
industry so we have also a number of
people with very very deep cannabis
expertise and those people help us
either in our consulting services
division or in our client services
division or actually in helping to
assist in designing and building the
product and then walk us through what a
experience would look like for someone
that comes on board MJ freeway so I'm
coming on board I'm now wanting to log
my seeds and with you and then watch how
they go to the end-user sure well we
have a operating team that works
our new clients so you would be assigned
to a particular lead on border that
would work with you throughout the
entire implementation process and that
person would help you set up all of your
systems do practice actions throughout
whatever you're going to do in the
system and then hold your hand as you go
live on the software and in full-time
operations and then the software itself
is showing what sort of insights to me
to make it worthwhile for me to keep
using mmm that's great so yes so
business intelligence is that the the
heart of what we do I spoke before about
both being part of the solution and
providing more value and one of the
areas in which we are seeing a real need
as our industry as cannabis continues to
mature and to consolidate and move
toward a more enterprise industry we are
seeing a greater need for competitive
insights for business intelligence data
so for instance I am a cultivator and
I'm growing two strains I'm growing
stirring a I'm growing strength B and
stream B actually sells for 10% more
than strain a but it costs 50 percent
more to produce so it's actually less
profitable and those are the types of
business insights that we provide
throughout the entire supply chain of
our product to help our clients be able
to understand their business better and
and how they can be more competitive
within the marketplace
yeah this is that that requires me to
manually input how much money I'm
putting into the strain for you - well
we automate a tremendous amount of that
so costs get associated with the product
and you know we are allowed this ability
to perform mass action so we make that
as easy as possible mm-hmm and then how
many companies or customers do you have
then in the approximate ballpark so we
serve thousands of businesses and
governments worldwide
that's right the government's two issues
so so the government's these are ones
that have come on four that are where
it's legal federally is that actually
current our two current government
contracts are with state governments
here in the United States so we have a
contract with the state of Washington
and with the Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania and we certainly have had
some conversations with other federally
legal governments but have not moved
forward at this time
interesting and then the government what
likes to use MJ freeway why so our
product for government systems leave
data systems is a track and trace
product so it's an aggregator of all of
the business management information
compliance data seed to sale data and
they use our product and and really what
we offer in leaf data systems that no
other cannabis technology provider
offers is that wealth of data from our
over eight and a half years of operation
we are able to really fine-tune the
pieces of government compliance around
well what is an accurate level of
moisture loss for a batch or what is the
expected yield from an extraction
operation and within what tolerance and
and those are the types of things that
governments want to be able to track in
order to ensure public safety product
safety and patient or consumer safety
yeah that's great
compliance and regulation and safety
yeah that's great so what is up with
this merger congratulations this is a
big deal this is huge
so yeah it's teach us about this so MJ
freeway has entered into a merger
agreement with M Tech which is a
publicly listed on the Nasdaq
special-purpose acquisition corporation
so commonly referred to as us back then
M Tech was formed for the purpose of
formed and listed on the Nasdaq for the
purpose of acquiring an ancillary
cannabis
company and we are the company that is
moving forward with these definitive
agreements and what it means to us is
really we expect to have around 60
million in cash on the balance sheet and
that allows us to execute our vision and
strategy in an even bigger way we're
really excited about the opportunity to
supercharge our organic growth and
really expand the reach and depth of MJ
platform as well as to look at some
potential strategic acquisitions wow
that's gonna be a lot 16 million is a
big cash infusion to be able to go off
and and also its public to give people
the public option to contribute and so
so every way so mtech was made to
specially acquire a company at a special
position and then did have a delay of
other acquisitions we are there the
target that they have selected and then
so now with the 60 million where do you
see yourselves moving forward so I'm
looking and thinking a lot about the
emerging global economy and with what we
are doing with MJ platform we already
have customers that are transacting
across country lines across multiple
currencies and I'm looking in thinking a
lot about an even broader set of tools
to serve that section of the emerging
economy I really think that that is the
the future of our global economy we're
working with some very large producers
and Colombia as well as some other
places that have import/export favorable
import-export laws and I think that will
truly change the face of our industry
over the next few coming years whoa I'm
justjust thinking about what I
understand about geopolitics and then
also trying to lump in cannabis into
that equation we
not only the agriculture but then also
the the trade of it a cross-border and
the currency and all that that's so
complicated and it's a huge part of
being able to get people medicine and
yeah so ok so that's a big focus then
it's a really fun problem to solve or I
should I should say it's a it's a fun
problem to offer solutions to address so
as I as I look at that and I think about
what we've done how we have been
successful to date is in solving all of
those little nitty-gritty details so for
instance the city of San Jose requires
that labels for cannabis be printed in
English French and Vietnamese in our
software we do in San Jose and as I look
at that and I consider what we get to do
and the type of solutions that we get to
provide worldwide and will continue to
provide worldwide but as that expands
and grows and and we expand from what is
currently our technology solutions
currently offered in three languages and
as I consider the solutions set of that
being offered and many many more
languages it's it's just very exciting
and I'm I'm excited to do that work yeah
and there's always this feeling of of
warmth or love that comes up when you
when you have the opportunity to use a
service that is in your language there's
always been like it almost feels as
though the company has given its love to
your language today they know that you
are gonna be using this and that you're
gonna be cared for and yeah that's nice
what is your what are you most looking
forward to in the cannabis industry
because the global economy you said that
there's so many different technologies
that are being integrated into cannabis
so what are you most looking forward to
you know we say a lot that we are
building a better industry not just
another industry and what I am most
looking forward to is this
really unique point of view that many of
the industry operators in cannabis are
coming from and how they're looking at
in the the spirit of cooperation and new
industry and new horizons and a product
that is very beneficial in many many
ways medically or in a even in a
nutraceutical type of application and
I'm most excited to work and continue to
work with an industry and group of
people who have that just shifted
mindset of we're building a better
industry not just another industry I
have a strong feeling that that what you
just said also relates for me to what is
being built with blockchain
infrastructure that it's it feels as
though that cannabis and blockchain are
similar in the sense that they're not
they don't just want another industry
they want a better industry I like that
quote that's a good one thanks for
having that value system we appreciate
it
this is what a lot of what we try and
communicate with our audiences that sort
of that shift in perception towards
better industries how can we be a part
of building the future the better
industries ok last question because you
are a powerful woman and we love to
speaking with powerful women how can we
help actualize more women into our world
well let me speak just for tech because
that is a passion area for me in an area
in which I've spent a lot of time and
energy and interestingly and
unfortunately what we see in tech is we
see these these two cliffs that women
women fall off the cliff so there's
either the cliff of they they never get
into stem they never enter the the
science tech engineering math fields or
once they get in interestingly over 50%
leave the field within the first 10
years and this usually happens because
they may be starting families they may
be doing be doing
something else and I will tell you what
we have dine at MJ freeway to help
address the second cliff and we said
look we're going to focus a lot on the
second cliff because that's an area in
which we are actively operating and we
employ female engineers and this second
cliff what we have done is we have
implemented a 30 hour full-time work
week and that is an available option at
our business for not every position in
our business but many positions have
that option and what it does we've got a
couple things around it we don't allow
any other employment so it's not for
somebody to work two jobs but if they
are working full-time they can have
full-time benefits work 30 hours a week
and have a balance of time for their
families and and what we've seen is
generally people take advantage of that
when they have very young children and
that's that's just four days at eight
hours a day pretty much so we usually
see is the five days but six hours
they're able to meet their kids when
they get out of preschool or out of you
know off the school bus or whatever that
may be mm-hmm drop them off and pick
them up and then you're working from
like nine till three exactly and what we
get is we get incredibly productive work
from these people who are very
intelligent very bright people who want
to continue to be challenged and to have
a career but they are balancing the
needs of their families as well and and
we've really I will tell you that out of
all of the people that we have offered
that option to so far they have all can
stayed with this long-term and convert
it to 40-hour work weeks eventually when
their children get older and what you're
describing right now is a flexible
dynamic ly adjusting system of work
culture that we're not we're not trying
to push square pegs through circular
hole you know there's just there's
everyone's like their own unique
experience lineage and they have to they
can be they can we can find ways to make
it so that our
the companies that were aiming to build
that have these missions that people
want to get behind that we can adjust
the workflows of the company to the
individual that so they can have family
and they can do the different things in
their life that's that's really good one
I like that one
and I and I root we we we have had the
opportunity to speak with so many
powerful women and we host like women
and Alliance panels and all these cool
things and you know one of the things
that we think is also really a key point
here is equality of opportunity I was I
was even shocked when I was like
respects really important and you know I
had a counter that actual equality of
opportunities even more important and I
was like wow and they kind of fit
together but just uh just the idea that
if you want the the stem feel to have
the female creative potential and female
tech and business potential which we
absolutely need then then the way a way
to do that is to provide those options
those opportunities yeah wow what a
pleasure thank you Jessica thank you so
much for coming out of the show and
talking with us thank you so much for
having me we really appreciate you thank
you and for everybody listening in and
tuning in thank you and also go and
manifest your destiny go create go and
build thank you for tuning in and we'll
see you soon
[Music]